[Music]
so george not only has uh bitcoin
dropped what 60 something percent now
since september big crash
um
that's not six that's
60. percent ouch
that means you turned 100 000 into 40.
uh but now we're seeing that a billion
dollars has been lost in crypto scams
according to the federal trade
commission
this is wild
cryptocurrency scammers have stolen over
1 billion dollars from 46 000 people
since the start of 2021 a new federal
trade commission report says ftc rang
the alarm bells on friday saying crypto
related crimes amount to about one out
of every four dollars reported lost to
fraud more than any other payment method
the meeting individual reported loss was
twenty six hundred dollars this is wild
um
crypto scams are becoming increasingly
popular shooting up 60 times higher than
in
2028.
uh nearly half of those who reported
losing money to a crypto scam in 2021
says they were lured in
through an online post or a social media
message so how are they getting scammed
do you know well on facebook and
instagram they lure you in
with you know they get you to
click the link go to a website and
there's been a lot of actual space scam
accounts impersonating me
trying to message people about crypto
and the people know it's spam and scams
once they go george is telling me to
invest in crypto i know this is a scam
so they report it and they let me know
like dave ramsey don't get a credit card
exactly
not a great move to the scammers out
there
and so that's what's happening and so
people get lured in and they go well
this seems you know this seems like a
good deal this seems like i'm going to
win big on this thing so they click it
and they give them access to their
crypto wallets and all kinds of things
and what are they what are they what are
they why would what are they buying i
mean what's the scam what are the what's
the pitch i have no idea what there's
all kinds of different ones out there uh
across the board
i don't know they have any details uh
here in both cases scammers promised
substantial returns to their investors
but instead pocketed the money into
their own crypto wallets so they're
promising you hey give us the money
we're going to give you an amazing
return on your money into this new
crypto coin
and all of a sudden those returns
disappear and they pocket the money
instead
and this is happening all over in
february a federal grand jury in san
diego indicted the founder of bit
connect
for allegedly orchestrating a 2.4
billion global ponzi scheme
founders accused of misleading investors
about the cryptocurrency's lending
program claiming company prop companies
proprietary technology would bring
substantive returns to investors by
tracking cryptocurrency exchange markets
so they all come down to this false
promises of easy money paired with
people's limited crypto understanding
and experience
so no one truly understands it and they
go away
you're saying someone who bought crypto
would fall for false promises of easy
money i just read the article i can't
believe that don't come at me in the
comment section
but that's the truth
it's so new it's so volatile the
technology is there and so people are
going well this is my chance what kind
of my point is is the very person who
buys
crypto to start with
uh is looking for a cutting edge easy
sophisticated technologically
uh
easy money
and so when someone presents them with
another cutting edge sophisticated
thing then they're more likely to fall
for that than the average joe because
they already are biting it they're
already chewing on that hook they're
trying to get on the ground floor of the
next thing they're trying to choose the
winning coins in other words the
scammers are taking them through the
same
psychological door that they went
through to buy bitcoin in the first
place and then they get scammed so
they're more susceptible
to scams and it's not it's all
unregulated so you're not protected
there's no fdic here going hey we'll
cover your money
and so you just lose this money
that's it
it's not hard
to steal people's crypto man
we've come a long way since the nigerian
prince this is the modern day version
at least i got a nice nicely worded
email from the nigerian prince i
remember getting uh
copies on a bad copy machine by snail
mail from the nigerian prince wow that
took effort yeah they and well it had my
name
personalized across the top of this
mo of this copy that had been made like
8 000 times so it had the lines and
stuff on it because you could tell it
was like it's like a mimeograph machine
or something like that yeah i'm old
enough i used to get those from the
nigerian prince i kind of missed those
days simpler times in the scamming world
simpler times man what was the one it
wasn't the spanish flu it was the
spanish lottery or something that ran
through canada really it was another one
you know that was
about 30 years of doing this you've seen
lots of scams
yeah
so uh glenn frashy who wrote the book
con manor saint
we talk about this in the building
wealth live event um he um
was claiming he might be a saint but he
wrote the book from prison so i'm
suspecting he was wrong
um that he was probably commenting he
ran he ran a ponzi scheme a true pyramid
scheme and got put in jail for it in the
70s
and um but he he was uh he was a
world-class con man
and uh
he said one of the quotes i read that
book you know when i was a teenager
i don't know how i ended up with it but
um
the quote i remember from the book more
than anything else i wouldn't pulled it
out for this event that we're doing
that he said you can con
someone of any intellect
any level of education
if you can activate greed or fear
and um
and they also they um
and really in a sense the part of the
greed one is pride
you know like you're in on something the
cool kids are in on it nobody except the
cool kids are in on it and you're one of
the cool kids you know you're not oh you
know people who aren't sophisticated
don't understand bitcoin
and uh you're obviously sophisticated
because you understand bitcoin and so
you're in bitcoin and since you're in
bitcoin we're going to give you this
other opportunity here it's your host
a billion
dollars
in scam
oh not to mention how many billions is
it is it over a trillion now in lost
value that it went down 60
yeah
so the total market value loss
of bitcoin i i read it it was an
astronomical number it's like a trillion
dollars or something when it went from
you know when it's gone down 60
that means people uh had value at some
point that hypothetically they could
have cashed in somewhere and didn't
and so they have now ridden this thing
to the bottom yeah we're seeing some
really sad stories of how much people
are losing in this who
they had a million dollars in it and now
they have nothing i was just reading a
heartbreaking story about one guy who's
honest enough to share his losses which
is pretty rare most of them only brag
about the wins
well it's like a bad golf game or a
fisherman that's right which you never
had a bad golf game so you don't have to
worry about that never caught a fish
either never
but it's pretty wild stuff so i mean you
know we talk about buyer beware but with
crypto it's a whole nother animal
because there's a whole technological
piece that most people don't understand
and i think i'm a pretty smart guy and
the more i look into crypto the more
confusing it gets
and i think they did that on purpose
no
that's like whole life it's really
complicated on purpose like well you
don't have to worry about it it gets
complicated just trust me give me the
premiums i'll give you the rest of me
trust me
trust me
yes oh man this is trying to find out
what this thing has done let's see here
in one
year
the losses yeah it's it's astronomical
this is wrong okay i was trying to pull
it up on a website while i'm on here
that's a dumb thing to do i'll tell you
that this guy he reportedly
uh he has a whole threat on twitter how
i went from a crypto millionaire to
broke in six months due to leverage a
gambling addiction and an accelerating
negative spiral and he goes through in
the thread about every single piece of
the puzzle that caused him to lose this
million dollars and now he's got nothing
he's sad he could have retired he could
have done a lot of things with that
money and that was a lot of regret
it's sad we like to make fun of crypto
but i don't like anyone losing a lot of
money that breaks my heart i won't be
hurt yeah but i i am
um more than a little bit
um
as much criticism as we took over from
the crypto that's true from the crypto
kids a little vindication yeah